Ngày Mi tăng thân mời tương mấy chính kênh một chungyên của tổn hàng lớn nhất lịch sử bởi khoảng bẩy trưởng người tham gia
phải hơn 2 nghìn bẩy trang để điểm.
Măng khổ hiểu Nấu Kinhs, Hôm Có Vua, Phong trào phản đối nhá mật cái chính sách và các tương đều hàng
của tổn thống đôn nân trang, cải thương khi ông trở lại nhà trắng.
Lời biểu tình chỉ trinh về tổn thống sự giống sách lại hàng pháp để liên chính ngân sách đã điều cuối hội thông qua
các giảm cửa liên bằng sách nhập cửa, át thuy đơn phân và chiến khách được vận biệt của gia dù vất phải giữ phản đối cùng của số bằng.
Đây là lần thứ ba của tổn hàng quý mô tổn cung diễn ra phản anh sẽ bất đồng ngày càng sâu sách về sân dựa quyền lực hàng pháp.
Những chuyện sách cho rằng những gì biến này đặt sách phải tức đối với thống kịp sách và kinh bằng quyền lực của Mỹ,
đồng thời cũng trở thấy sá hôm Mỹ đang bị phân cửa hoàn hơn.
Sức đồng thời có quyết sách tiếp theo của nhà chắng, chưa có cảnh của bầu cử vẫn còn phía trước.